hey i'm ryan right and i'm andre us sick
stuff welcome to reasons to see or not
to see know what where we give you
reasons to see and not to see frozen
so let's hang out with jazz hands reason
to see number one a good kids movie so
yeah we saw frozen frozen is uh it's a
great movie it's a great kids movie you
know it's got some strong messages in
there like loving yourself embracing who
you are
yes don't judge yourself no judging
mmm-hmm love one another all the good
kids messages that are out there these
days
yes biggest moral the story was to love
and be loved and accept them and you
know there was a lot of people saying
like how incredible this one was i
thought it was just okay yeah it wasn't
all that spectacular but I mean it was
fun fun quick short movie like like it's
it's really fast-paced and it's really
zany it's like yes not the most original
of movies yeah I mean it was good though
had some good musical numbers to it did
I'm not particularly a musical sort of
person but I enjoyed it it was good
solid fun music see you don't feel
that's the only song I remembered reason
to say number two Anna yeah it was good
and then like you know you got good
characters in there too you got like the
main girl well there's like two main
girls I guess the main one would be the
younger sister yeah yeah she was
definitely the more focus yeah Anna is
her name played by Anna she knows who
plays her Kristen Bell really yeah she
is one of my favorites because she is
she oh man I would do things Andrea I
would do things sir okay yes yeah this
is a kids movie keep it PG PG okay
they're gonna learn one day okay what
they're gonna know what sex is one day
especially when I release my porno with
Kristen Bell the attic character she's
really funny she's a funny funny person
and a cute little girl she was yeah you
know she's pretty she's pretty toes
watching the animation going this is
pretty fine-looking girl why are you
sweating so much
oh because I just gotta have the shower
and I worked out and I didn't have
enough food you worked out after your
shower no before I just told you the
sentence improperly I like women in real
life were like Anna you know quirky and
goofy romantic same time you know very
driven and you know ambitious that's
cool yeah kind of like this girl over
here okay yeah I mean she's no Hannah I
would be enemies yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly exactly you don't want to [ __ ]
with this girl breezing a seat number
three is Seth and the sisters good to
the sister Chris Elsa Elsa Elsa is great
she has the froze I had no idea what
this movie was about for a song I think
that was the coolest power though like
yes it was something she definitely
should have embraced I mean she froze
things and made them sparkly and mm-hmm
you know I see yeah you have described I
said you got a good balance of both
characters this one is like really good
really sweet and loves herself already
and then you got one character who's
like represses all her emotions and has
to hide from society you know someone
who's just out of touch with themselves
and I think a lot of people will
identify with that character it's a
great balance for kids you know and to
have a good learning lessons I like this
movie more than I thought I did actually
cuz yeah there's a lot of great things
in there and the house is pretty cool
she's hot too yeah they're both very
gorgeous yeah they got a you know good
good genes and their family animation is
spectacular - well I want to say
spectacular it's pretty good it was
really cool how the whole city just went
just iced over yeah that's a really cool
scene oh there's this one moment where
oh this is one moment where she like
builds a castle out of ice and I was
like that's some pretty cool [ __ ] right
there it makes you want to have the
power because you know you hear the
power of like oh this person has can
turn anything with ice or whatever you
know and you're like oh that sounds
alright but then when you see it in this
movie it's done in a way where only an
animation can pull this show yeah it's
like when I saw The Incredibles I was
thinking only animation can do a
superhero movie like this
same thing with with frozen house like
only an animation can do that kind of
thing and suspend you in that you know
reality be cool and be really cold but
it'd be cool I mean yeah but when you're
an ice queen mm-hmm you mean you want
the ice powers and the ice castle yes oh
I thought you might just an ice castle I
was like well first off I don't know who
plays him but he's a he's a cool
character you know he's that charming
kind of like I don't know kid from the
wrong side of the tracks but he's like
really sweet at the same time you know
he's a he's a cool guy they got cool
characters in this film they're they're
great characters for kids rarely do you
get characters with like yeah you can
you can learn from these people and
these people grow and it's about people
to most the time stalling animals or
something yeah I mean they did have a
talking snowman imagine yeah there's the
talking snowman relief it was dope so he
was so funny he was a funny guy
he had me laughing he was a guy you know
man
that is true I'm trying to eat his nose
so I would be Ryan's good census a great
animated movie that is not a Pixar film
is the reason to see frozen a great
animated movie that is not a Pixar film
is the reason to see frozen yeah it's
it's a good kids film
I wouldn't say like oh it's one of the
best family movies I've ever seen but as
far as the age range they're going for
parents can
nor this movie and kids will love it
Andres Consensus a great family film is
the reason to see frozen a great family
film is the reason to see frozen when I
started watching the movie I thought
that I should have my nephew sitting
nice to me because it was such wonderful
kids movie it you know gave the greatest
message for children and adults alike so
it was it was great all right guys
thanks for checking out a review for
frozen why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below and tell us what
do you think of Kristen Bell if you want
to see more reviews from reasons to see
click on the link right here and last
but not least if you want to get updated
every time one of our reviews or video
is out subscribe click this button right
here that we got more than just movie
reviews we got like we got trailer
reviews movie news
trailer reactions everything yeah just
one big movie shall we even just
sketches oh man and a short film no we
have a single short film so this is
really but I've been looking at oh what
she means by that is the thing is
flipped over so she's looking at herself
you should you're pretty good-looking
person if I was as good-looking as you I
would carry a mirror with me everywhere
I want message to the kids out there if
you end up being good-looking carry a
mirror with you and of course you'll get
laid to all the kids out know this this
show is for adult audiences only adult
audiences and black people it's got an
awkward in here
you